And the answer I'm looking for, obviously, is the thing we just talked about--
replicate the database.
Now, yes, you can get a faster machine,
but sometimes you don't have access to a faster machine,
and that's obviously not what I was asking.
Of course, you can store less data.
That was something we used to say. I read it all the time.
This site would be a lot faster if we didn't have any users.
Or you could press the turbo button,
which is really just a subset of get a faster machine.
I don't know if you guys remember computers with turbo buttons,
but they were pretty cool.
But the answer I'm looking for is replicate the database.
If you take your database and you replicate the data
to a bunch of different machines, you can do more reads.
So, all right, next quiz.